deux résultats positifs dans ce domaine
merci la parole et à monsieur philippe
cochet monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle est l'autorité de l'état quand un
premier ministre et son ministre de
l'intérieur parts de sauvageons quand ce
sont des meurtriers qui attaquent les
forces de l'ordre à viry châtillon
d'un point de vue pénal ses auteurs
peuvent être poursuivis pour tentative
de meurtre voire tentative d'assassinât
c'est la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase pour les policiers mais
aussi les gendarmes et en général pour
les forces de l'ordre la lâcheté de
l'état et son manque de thé flagrant
déstabilise une fonction régalienne qui
est la sécurité des personnes et des
biens
quand vous promettez des pare-brises
anti projections et des tenues ignifuges
y est la traduction directe des
policiers a été de dire ah c'est bon on
peut nous jeter des cocktails molotov
maintenant mais pour qui prenez vous les
policiers ils manifestent non pas car il
manque de moyens ce n'est pas un
problème de crayon ou de plein d'essence
deux véhicules de police ces femmes et
ces hommes exercent leur métier avec un
sens aigu du service public
nous sommes en plein état d'urgence et
nos policiers continuent chaque soir de
recevoir notamment sur eux des boules de
pétanque jeter des toits de zones de non
droit il échappe à des émeutes dans des
quartiers et sont blessés
qu'ils soient policiers gendarmes
pompiers médecin secouriste
il n'en peut plus de l'impunité de votre
manque d'autorité
chaque nuit les policiers se rassemblent
dans toute la france
et encore aujourd'hui devant les
tribunaux pour échanger régulièrement
avec eux je vous rassure ils aiment leur
métier et ne font pas de politique
contrairement à ce qu'affirme en bon
commissaire politique
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste qui lui aussi est
complètement hors sol ils sont
simplement écoeuré qui avouent les avait
abandonnés avec votre politique laxiste
en termes de sécurité de nos réponses
face à une telle carence se pose
clairement la question de la légitime
défense de nos forces de l'ordre le
risque ne peut pas être uniquement du
côté de ceux qui protègent des français
monsieur le premier ministre
de l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve
monsieur le député quand on est attaché
à l'autorité de l'état et condom menée
dans le respect des policiers je
rappelle que l'un d'entre eux est
actuellement hospitalisé à l'hôpital
saint louis
il y a des formes d'abaissement de la
parole publique qu'on s'interdit au sein
de la représentation nationale et je
pense franchement monsieur le député
qu'on doit s'interdire cet abaissement
de la parole publique qui ne vous
concerne pas seul puisque j'ai été
qualifié par l'un de ceux que vous
semblez soutenir de celui qui sert de
mise de l'intérieur ce qui témoigne
vraiment d'un niveau très élevé de la
parole publique et de la pensée
politique quand on abaisse à ce point la
parole politique faut pas voir le bilan
que vous avez vous êtes celui qui
s'exprime au nom d'un groupe qui a
supprimé 13 bis l'emploi au sein des
forces de police et de gendarmerie vous
exprimer en donnant des leçons
aujourd'hui alors que vous avez diminué
de 15%
les crédits de fonctionnement de la
liste c'est de la gendarmerie et qu'il
ya aujourd'hui des commissariats qui
sont pas rénovés des véhicules qui sont
en état d'obsolescence que précisément
nous sommes en train de rénover et de
remplacer sous l'autorité du premier
ministre
vous parlez de l'autorité de l'état dans
les quartiers mais vous imaginez vous
monsieur le député que les policiers de
france ignore comme les gendarmes que
vous avez supprimé en cinq ans quinze
unités de forces mobiles qui ne manquent
cruellement
partout en france pour assurer le
maintien de l'ordre alors vous êtes en
train parce qu'il y à une exercice qui
s'appelle la primaire de verser des
larmes de crocodile sur le sort de ce
que vous n'avez cessé d'affaiblir par
les décisions budgétaires et les
décisions politiques que vous avez
prises alors je peux vous le dit
monsieur le député les policiers je les
rencontre tous les jours et depuis des
années il m'a dit fais ce effectivement
une colère mais la colère crédit faith
hill à manifeste surtout à l'égard de
l'état de déshérence dans lequel vos
amis ont lesté la police et la
gendarmerie et que nous sommes en train
de corriger par nos décisions et rien de
votre démagogie ne parviendra à les
convaincre
parce que par votre démagogie vous les
mémorisez et vous abaissez la parole
politique
merci
merci si vous voulez